envie de booster bonbons chocolats ou
d'une boisson gazeuse
voilà des aliments qui sont omniprésents
dans notre environnement et
particulièrement autour de caisse quand
vient le temps pays et remâchant des
gens vont dire souvent sivu est vendu un
placement au 15 fait partie d'une
stratégie très lucratif où on suscite
des enchères qui sont impulsifs et que
la part du temps les consommateurs vont
même regretter cet achat
c'est sur la chaîne pulsé fondu au
niveau des magasins d'alimentation c'est
presque 80% des achats sont décidés sur
le lieu de vente
l'un des achats impulsifs par excellence
se fait souvent alors qu'on est en
attente dans la file dans des corridors
qui ne cesse de s'allonger distanciation
oblige
ce sont des produits qui ont un support
promotionnel donc eu une négociation
souvent avec l'acheteur de catégories
qui va permettre d'avoir cette
exposition la plus apparent pour les
consommateurs donc il ya des ententes
commerciales qui sont réalisés entre les
deux partenaires
c'est la santé en ce moment qu'il y en
ait coop et c'est surtout ce marketing
là qu'il faut encadrer ailleurs dans le
monde
des mesures sont prises en ce sens par
exemple aux états unis dans la ville de
berck les une loi interdit toute vente
d'aliments trop gras trop sucrés et trop
salés aux caisses des commerces en
australie et au royaume uni
plusieurs autres mesures sont prises on
a vu récemment au royaume uni que non
seulement au fait le ménage aux caisses
mais on empêche aussi certains
placements dans d'autres espaces de
l'épicerie on empêche la promotion du
deux coureurs par exemple parce que ce
sont des façons d'inciter à la
surconsommation donc d'encadrer le
marketing c'est faisable
je pense que c'est nécessaire de prendre
des mesures de cette nature loeb pour
cette professeure en droit de la santé
il est important d'agir c'est plus vrai
lorsque se consacrer uniquement à
l'individu pierre en décembre de
sensibiliser les ducs et l'informé c'est
suffisant
dix fois notre volonté personnelle des
limites c'est ça que j'ai trouvée quand
même intéressant bouclions s'est pas dit
on vendre refus de produits ks néanmoins
vendre des produits sains alors là avec
la fonte des nids qui allongent les
files d'attentes ont ni probablement
plus exposé aux entre exposé plus
longtemps à ces produits non
mais c'est peut-être l'occasion que les
chantiers ou de repenser la façon dont
les commerces ont fait c'est possible de
réglementer le tallage dans les
commerces
ces deux compétences provinciales
marianne des sureaux avocate à
l'association pour la santé publique
étudie la question
la clé de l'égalité c'est dans le
compromis
c'est dans une interdiction partielle à
mon sens ce serait permis par la loi de
faire une petite entorse à cette liberté
commerciale qu'il ya la liberté
commerciale à considérer mais aussi
démontré que ces aliments ont un lien
direct avec la santé comme c'est le cas
pour la cigarette par exemple on l'as
aussi souvent en magasin d'alimentation
mais on le voit de plus en plus dans les
magasins qui ne sont pas d'alimentation
je pense qu'il faut garder qui sont les
plus grands fautifs une pratique
répandue de la pharmacie au magasin de
vêtements le présentement au québec on
essaie de valoriser davantage les
aliments frais et 5 chez nous comme les
fruits légumes et pourquoi on
n'occuperait pas cet espace-là aux
caisses pour promouvoir les aliments
d'ici que son sein dans ce quartier en
plein développement
une nouvelle épicerie de la famille
barcelo tente de faire les choses
autrement
on préfère mettre de l'avant justement
des produits québécois que des produits
maraîchers
un bon pour la santé qu'est ce que tu
lis le montrent il montre la section des
courses pour le placer à l'avant des
cayes ici dans le parcours d'attentes
aux caisses on se retrouve face à un
comptoir de courge là bas une armoire de
noix ou encore un frigo de kombucha spa
de l'alcool oui c'est sucre ayant donné
moins sucré cette chienlit ce qu'on est
habitué de voir les clients sont plus
informés quand tu cherches une épicerie
devaient le retrouver leurs produits
locaux qu'on essaie de mettre de l'avant
le plus possible pour papoter des
caisses à ce qu est un bon outil de mise
en marché c'est un bon endroit pour leur
donner la plus belle visibilité qui peut
avoir quand les gens entendent 15
seulement ils voient les produits c'est
sûr que c'est pas un produit des achats
impulsifs
c'est vraiment un produit que les gens
ont des seins six femmes ça serait beau
ça serait bon ce qu'on observe en
australie où on ne fait ce genre
d'initiative
les gens ont juste transféré leurs
achats donc tout le monde est gagnant
sauf peut-être la grande industrie
alimentaire ct-paiement perdu certains
chiffres devant et quand même si
présentoirs de croustilles oui on essaie
de faire des choses un peu différentes
mais il ya encore de la demande pour ce
type de produits à la base nous on fait
ça par passion ça votre choix de
s'adapter on peut pas nier que ce sont
des acteurs dans cette chaîne le
finalement qui mène au choix du ou des
aliments
on pourrait tenter de pousser la
question au niveau légal juridique mais
je pense que c'est avant tout une
question d'éthique sociale
cette philosophie on essaie d'évoluer là
dedans parce que c'est un premier pas
changer les choses tranquillement pauvre
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de cet
environnement-là entourant les caisses
c'est un passage obligé ips de passage
qui va s'alléger de plus en plus avec la
technologie on aura des caisses
automatiques et de complètement
interdire c'est peut-être une décision
qui ne résout pas nécessairement la
question alors il faut il faut qu'une
collaboration au canada présentement ses
26 milliards de dollars que ça nous
coûte en maladies associées à une
mauvaise alimentation
c'est énorme on n'interdit pas la
consommation de ces aliments là on
interdit même paul avant
de ces aliments là on modifie les
conditions de vent pour essayer de les
marginaliser
un peu plus part sont prédominants dans
nos environnements alimentaire alors que
par souci de cohérence devrait l'être -
étant donné qu'on recommande par exemple
selon le guide alimentaire canadien
d'éliminer ou en train de réduire
considérablement la consommation de ces
aliments